they repay annuals policy if it is to be
effective must be both visionary and
pragmatic more than half a century ago
an ambitious vision of the European
defense community was created but what
was missing was the unity and courage to
put it into practice since then this
idea was revisited many times but to no
effect the dream was at odds with
reality today this dream becomes reality
we are launching permanent structured
cooperation so-called pesco which is a
practical expression of our will to
build European defence in the debate
before today's decision the main dilemma
was how to make basketball's inclusive
and ambitious vesko in which 25 member
states take part is for sure inclusive
and if all the commitments are fulfilled
pesco will also be ambitious for many
years the strongest argument against
Pascal had been the fear that it would
lead to the weakening of NATO but it is
quite the opposite
strong European defence naturally
strengthens NATO this is why pesco is
not only good news for us but it is also
good news for our allies and the bad
news
you